this is you you're almost done with your
first semester at Hillsdale so far it's
been amazing and you've learned a lot
and surprisingly a lot about yourself
learned you like photography and you
crave the rush of staying up late
crafting a captivating article for the
collegian the campus newspaper you now
have a dream of one day becoming a
photojournalist for Time magazine
fantasies but there is a small problem
you don't really know how to get there
you have a few options a you can decide
writing in photography aren't real jobs
so instead of developing your talents
you double down on classes you don't
really like or be do you think I'm young
and the future is well in the future so
you waste all your time on social media
worse comes to worse you like coffee you
could probably get hired as a barista or
see you can head down to Career Services
located beneath the old snack bar across
the hall from academic services this is
Ken coupons and the Career Services team
Career Services helps you figure out how
you can use your skills and passions to
influence your academic and career paths
they connect you with alumni help you
find internships give you resume advice
and help you figure out how to do what
you love in the future because who are
you kidding
you're a terrible barista you can't even
make drip coffee
[Music]